un élève de CM2 ramène un pochon de
cocaïne dans son école primaire voici ce
que l'on sait ça s'est passé à l'école
Paul Langevin à bobini ce mardi 21
novembre l'enfant a été surpris en train
de manipuler devant ses camarades un
petit pochon d'environ 1 g pendant la
récréation selon le parquet de bobini
d'après plusieurs camarades personne n'a
ouvert le sachet aucun élève n'a donc
ingéré de cocaïne l'enseignant à qui ce
pochon a été remis a d'abord cru que
c'était de la farine mais a vite
suspecté cette foute d'être un produit
illicite d'après les informations du
Parisien comment l'enfant s'est retrouvé
en possession de ce sachet d'après les
déclarations de l'élève il aurait trouvé
le pochon de cocaïne au pied d'un Trond
d'arbre sur le chemin de l'école il
n'avait pas d'autrre sachet sur lui ou
dans son cartable sa mère n'est pas
connu des services de police mais il a
tout de même été ordonné d'effectuer une
perquisition au domicile familial rien
de suspect n'a été découvert durant les
fouilles d'après le maire de la ville
Abdel Sadi c'est la toute première fois
qu'un incident de la sorte se produit
dans une école de Bobin pour l'instant
aucune plainte n'a été déposée par la
ville mais le maire a indiqué qu'il
comptait s'assurer qu'il n'y a eu aucune
défaillance dans le fonctionnement des
services municipaux dans cette affaire
la provenance exacte de la drogue n'a
pas été déterminée le parquet a classé
sans suite l'enquête